つまり意欲と能力って違うんですよ信用
信頼できない人だけは採用しちゃだめです
でもし仮に入れてしまったらどうする
かっていう話なんだけどそれは諦めないと
これはもう真心1本勝負青木サの人生経営
哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですね絶対にうん雇ってはいけ
ない社員の特徴について教えますでしょう
[音楽]
か雇っちゃいけない人はともかくね不正実
な人僕ね1番苦手なのはねその場しのぎの
うまいこと言って事故正当化したりそれ
からま自己正当化するってことは多にし
ますよねこれその人自身の人間的な所用と
して分かりやすく言えば信用信頼できない
人これねどんなに能力があっても信用信頼
できない人だけは採用しちゃだめです人は
みんな利己的なんですよこれはしょうが
ないんですよ自分の命を守るためにその
ように遺伝子に組み込まれているからただ
それがあまりにも自分中心だと
チームワーク
が乱れますよねでやっぱり価値観の違う人
ま分かりやすく言えば反射のような考え方
の人って合わないじゃんだから自分の価値
観に合わない人は採用しないてことと思う
のよだから1番愚かなのは履歴書見て大学
を見て採用するとか偏差値見てそれを熟に
こういう大学の人間以下は全部足切りしろ
みたいなそういう面接する会社もある
らしいのよでも俺はちょっとおかしいん
じゃないかなと思うやっぱりもちろんそれ
はなんと嫌なことを先延ばしするとかお
受験しなかった人とか勉強苦手な人って
どっちかっていうと目の前の課題に対して
真正面に向き合えなかった人もいるかも
しれないあとはその無目的無目標な学生
時代を過ごしてしまってあのすごく時間を
無駄にしてしまった人もいるかもしれない
だけどま私なんかは23歳で成功哲学
っっていう本に出会ってそこで私はあの
燃えるような願望これが自分の中に
やっぱり生まれてなんとしてもこういう
人間になりたいこういう成果を出せる人間
になりたいこれ全部自分の内側からだこれ
は
採用したい人材だけどこのエネルギーと
会社が目指す方向が一致してるばいい人材
なんだよねでもまずこのエネルギーがない
人間もうネガティブで人と一緒に何か
チームを組んで仕事をすることに対して
障害を持ってる利己的な人はやっぱり採用
してもうまくいかないですよねそういう
ところは注意深く選ばなきゃいけないと
思う大学で選ぶとかなんかそういう選び方
なんか本質的じゃない選び方をするのは
会社自体にも問題があるんだけどでも基本
的にはやっぱり自分の価値観に合わない人
は入れない方がいいと私は思いますだから
必ず僕は最終面談するんですよそれなんで
かって言うとま私はあの結婚相手をね選ぶ
のとよく似てると思うんですよどんな人が
結婚相手にふさわしいのかって言った時に
家柄がよく大金持ちでハンサムでねそんな
はなかなかいないじゃんだけど僕なんかは
家柄もなく学校歴もなく17歳で社会出て
どん底にからはい上がってきたわけでうち
の奥さんが僕を選んだ時は僕は負債もあっ
たんですよそれでも僕を選んだじゃ何が
ポイントだと思うかってことだよねそれは
僕は誠実だったってことですよある人が
青木さんそんなね力まなくていいんじゃ
ないのって採用なんてのは恋愛みたいな
もんだからわかんないじゃないともう
裏切られたり捨てられたりするよってで僕
はそうは思わないのよ僕からは誠実に絶対
手は離さないよと約束したじゃないかと
いついかなる時もこのものと共に歩むって
いう約束をした以上はという結婚と同じで
だそれぐらい真剣勝負なのでやっぱり価値
観の合わない人は最初にはっきりと
いろんな質問けていく中ででよく言うのは
まるまるさんと正直に言ってくださいと
大変申し訳ないんですけど今採用チーム4
人ね真剣に皆さんを採用したいと思って
フルタイムで4人頑張ってくれました彼ら
が後で採用が決まった後やっぱりやめます
と内定辞退しますというようなことは彼ら
ががっかりしますし僕は大変申し訳ない
けど社員がですだ社員を落胆させるような
ことはしたくないので本音本心でご自身ま
いろんなまだ会社これからをもっともっと
見ていきたいという気持ちもあるでしょう
からまだそこまで共感してないんなら本音
のとこでやめといてもいいと思いますよ
それぐらい1歩も2本も踏み込んだ僕は
本音を伝えますそしてそこで何か相手の目
の動きや
や出てくるオーラみたいなものがあってあ
これは本気だなとか誠実ななとかそういう
ことを感じ
たら採用でちょっと不誠実だないやこれは
あくまでも踏み台にしようとしてキャリア
を積んで次にまた行くつもりだなとか
なんか感じたら慎重にしますねこれね
ポイントなんですよ実は事前の一手は事後
の100手にまさるこれ僕の人生の特徴な
んだけど結婚してからその後苦労するより
も結婚前の段階で吟味するとだから愛に
入社させないんですよやっぱり誠実な人間
再のある人間志しのある人間だからじゃ
そんな人どこにいるのってだからを広げ
なきゃいけないだよねたくさんの数の中
からまたそういういろんな
インターンシップとかいろんなことやり
ながらいい人材を行動観察して見てきて
人事が是非この人と一緒に働きたいという
人を上げてきてその中で最終面談でそれを
確認をしてそして入れる入れないを決め
てるだけなんですよだ基本的にはもう人事
の採用プロセスの中で例えば時間をを守る
守らないとかね約束を守れない人間は採用
しない約束を守る人間は採用する
コミュニケーション能力が高い人間は採用
コミュニケーション能力低ければ不採用
なるしでそういう1つ1つの
アチューメントが大事にしている文化に
一致してる人を採用しているそんなことか
なありがとうございます正直その採用した
後に雇ってはいけなかったなっていうこと
もまゼロではない思うですねなんかそう
いう時ってどうされるんですか
[音楽]
うんあるんだこれがまたたまにね1年に
どうかなうん1人か2人ぐらいあるなで
最近なくなったけどやっぱそれは採用ミ
スってやつですよねでそれ何がポイント
かって言うとやっぱりね実を見てなかった
んだわつまり意欲と能力って違うんですよ
これ能力をしっかりるだ僕ね若い時のね
失敗団をねあえて言うとね私あの北海道
出身に弱いわけあとあの選択理論に出会っ
て人生良くなりましたって言われちゃうと
めっちゃ情が入っちゃうねあと
クリスチャンに弱いわけよねこの3つこれ
ね何かと言うと潜入感だよねあそうなんだ
俺も俺どさこよみたいなこれこんなんで
クラっちゃあっちゃったらどうしようも
ないじゃんもう大体これうまくいったこと
ないですよあんまりっっていうことはね
やっぱり本質的長期的客観的な視点にたっ
た採用をしなきゃいけないでもし仮に入れ
てしまったらどうするかっていう話なんだ
けどそれは諦めないとこれはもう真心1本
勝負それがアーメントという会社です私は
それでいいと思ってるだって自分の子供が
非行化したからと言って親は諦めない
じゃん引きこもりになったからって諦め
ないじゃん絶対諦めないじゃんそれが指導
者の持つべき心のあり方だと私は思って
ますだからうちの管理職はみんな上が深い
です
[音楽]
よまあの本来はねだから不誠実であったり
不誠実ってことは約束守れないってこと
でしょだからコミュニケーションスキルが
非常に低いさらにはま利己的だとかで
やっぱこう批判的な反対性のような考えと
かまいろんなそういう人間的な所用の中で
人とうまくやっていけない人は採用しちゃ
いけないですよね元々人間として好感度が
高く誠実で前向きで人とうまくやって
いけるそしてあとはうちの仕事で言うと
人在教育に対する共感そういうものが強い
人を採用したら良いと思うんですよその
真逆は採用しちゃいけない人っていうこと
になると思うんだよねだからまご自分が
まず自分でどんな人在を採用したいかを
まず先に整理したらいいと思うその特徴を
その火状とかね整理してその全く真逆の
ことをこっちに書いてその真逆の要素を
持ってる人は採用しないと決めたらま
うまくいくという風に思いますよ僕も38
年あっちぶつかりこっちぶつかりしながら
経してきましたでも今の会社の発展がある
のはやっぱり採用と育成そこに力を入れた
からです是非チャレンジしてくださいえ
是非ねえチャンネル登録してくださいあと
コメント欄にも是非コメントお願いします
えまた次回のYouTubeでおめに帰り
ましょうありがとうございます
決して負けない経営なまず経営者自身がお
金よりも仕事の内容そのものに惚れ込ん
でるかどう
かは